let me go next to our caller from the
2:03 area code who's calling today from
203
hello David can you hear me yes I can
who is this so I am Joe Harris I'm from
Connecticut which is you dove
Massachusetts but as only you would know
being from Massachusetts it's next to
Massachusetts no one else knows where it
is
Connecticut a great place it's a great
place where a lot of people who work in
New York City live in fact yeah yes very
that's why kovat was a little scary but
now I Mountain Pittsburgh so Larry bye
anyway my big question was as someone
who's a younger person I'm not exactly
excited about Joe Biden but so can him
as president would obviously be better
than Trump right on these down ballot
races in the Senate do you think there's
any way the Democrats could take the
Senate I feel like Susan Collins main
maybe that I'm seeing Montana and
Arizona
I think it's Mark Kelly or something in
Arizona yep but do you think there's any
way we can push 50 51 or is that
unlikely oh no I mean listen it's an up
if you said to me I have to it's a even
money bet who do I bet keeps control I
probably bet on Republicans but there's
a very clear path for Democrats and it
does include as you mentioned Mark Kelly
in Arizona
you've got Cory Gardner who who is
potentially facing defeat in Colorado -
Hickenlooper in fact it looks like
Hickenlooper is gonna win we had some
polling from Montana that says Steve
Bullock could win there you I'm not
going to remember all of them North
Carolina you've also got Maine as you
mentioned so yeah I've outlined a path
that is not it's not overwhelmingly
likely but it's certainly feasible for
Democrats to take control of the Senate
and you know when I see a poll that says
Texas is tied between Trump and Biden
that's the type of shift that would
likely go along with Democrats taking
control of the Senate but all we can do
is get out and vote and we've got to
make sure that we do that okay yeah cuz
I I have like the deepest level of
disdain for miss Mitch McConnell like
the Trump evil Amy McGrath and Mitch
McConnell's another example exactly even
even like Lindsey Graham
Carolina like I such deep disdain he's
like destroying our country on purpose
and I like hate that guy so much that if
he lost that power he'd be huge for us
it would be absolutely yeah so don't
forget that's a good one
Lindsey Graham has an opponent in South
Carolina I believed young Harrison even
though certainly it's an up high there's
a lot of races here that we should be
looking at no question about it fight
every single one of them and it would be
amazing amazing to take control of the
Senate and because listen if Biden wins
in November and the Senate control
remains with Republicans that
dramatically limits how much Biden can
get done in terms of major legislation
hopefully executive orders to reverse a
lot of the atrocities Trump has done but
you're going to struggle to get big
legislation done and that's why taking
the Senate would be just fantastic well
yeah and then we can just push and push
and just roll over the Republicans
absolutely there the other reason
progressives should really want to take
the Senate is that we want if you I
don't want to put the cart before the
horse I probably said that a dozen times
this week if Joe Biden becomes president
we want to be best positioned to force
Biden to be as progressive as possible
if there's a Republican Senate it's
unlikely Biden is going to be tested
with any / seriously progressive bills
if the Republicans lose the Senate
Democrats and in the House and Senate
will potentially pass some pretty
progressive stuff the Senate is not
super progressive even the Democrats in
the Senate are not the most progressive
people but we can put stuff on Biden's
desk where it's like is he gonna veto
that stuff that's the the ideal scenario
where we can force some stuff onto
Biden's desk no yeah exactly exactly
that was that was my big question I'm
like a huge fan of yours thank you all
the videos you're awesome you're smart
you make great points I presume if you
kind of what I'm thinking about though
thank you for your time
I'm glad you called very much appreciate
it that is going to do it for calls
today we were going to go to a break but
I do plan on taking calls again in the
future if you were unable to get on
today